on the lancashire hills they've created
a giant sponge dotted across holcomb
moore are more than 3 000
pools dug into the peat they should slow
the flow of water
that used to flood the towns below
this is a sphagnum plug nick helped
plant half a million patches of moss
that should thrive in the boggy
conditions it takes many times its own
weight in
in in water so again it's
quite right to say it's a sponge it's
like a giant sponge over over a hundred
hectares
that we're trying to create here and
this little plant here that's been
around for millennia
um we always knew we're important but
really is relevant to modern day society
because this little plant
can is the key to all the success on
this on this project
in a healthy bog the moss sucks in
carbon from the air as it grows
when it dies it doesn't rot because the
ground is so wet
it becomes peat with a carbon locked
away for thousands of years
but on holcomb moore over grazing by
sheep and 150 years of air pollution
have destroyed the fragile moss blanket
a little bit that's been exposed during
the
moorland works and you can see that this
has dried out because
it's been on the surface and you can see
how crumbly it is
and it just the wind takes it and any
water would just take that away
and degrade it and once you start to get
gullies then
you know it just exacerbates the problem
so once it's all vegetated then the
peat's protected
but this success is barely a hundred
hectares the peat problem
is far bigger peat covers three million
hectares in the uk
and it stores three billion tonnes of
carbon that's more than all the forests
of the uk
france and germany put together but it
is so dry that it's releasing
20 million tons of carbon every year
that's 4
of the uk's annual emissions the
government says it will now fund larger
projects elsewhere
we've made a commitment to restore 35
000
hectares of peatland by 2025 well that's
only in four years time
and we've already got the measures in
place to set that in motion
repairing the damage took six months but
the benefits will be felt for
generations to come
thomas more sky news on holcomb moore